hello there reject nation today we're gonna check
out spiderman no way home gag reel and behind the
scenes but before we go into that the reason
i'm doing my terrible rick impression because
i want to shout out today's video sponsor which
is the walking dead no man's land the official
mobile role play game for amc's the walking dead
no man's land immerses you in the world of the
walking dead over thousands of hours of content
across multiple game modes including story based
missions pulled from the show itself second
half of the final season is airing right now
which means new game content after each new
episode i just think this is what someone in
the show sounds like yep that means new playable
characters new weapons missions and events ripped
straight out of the show every move you make
has consequences including those voices so it's
the perfect way to put your zombie apocalypse
skills to the test go lone wolf like greg alba
or join other survivors in guild challenges the
choice is yours you can download the game today
by hitting our special link in the description
box so scanning that nifty qr code on screen and
when you use promo code the real rejects it's in
all caps you'll receive 40 michonne tokens plus
her signature katana now through march 31st no
man's land is available free for ios and android
so once this video's done you know what to do
that's not how you do it you know what to do
hey what's going on guys it's jacob and zade
here we're about to show you the bloopers
sometimes movie making seems very serious
but a lot of times comedy gold happens
well there's a lot of falling and swearing
i hope that they'll bleep that out
blooper reel i think it's time to go roll it nice
feels like something out of euphoria for
some reason prop comedy let's save me mj
yikes oh wow okay
have you been rolling this off
hey hey holland here buddy let me help you here
keep the seals tight that's right he did sorry
oh my god there's other nets out
there i wonder what they're like
what if there's one where we don't even
live in the same same neighborhood or like
the same state like that and
it's like nebraska and you're
you got a spider web on you
that's because i'm sprite
you do it right there
there's a that's gotta hurt electric man a sand
man there's a dinosaur man there's an octopus man
and then there's this old man
yes
sorry
whatever
there's
wait wait wait i love you guys
okay okay go from where go from before go from
before peter one peter two two peter three sure
the avengers the avengers what's
that i love you you're killing
shut me prove it oh
nice
wow look how fun that looks yeah oh so many
people got to be putting backgrounds on these
oh they look like they're having so much fun ah
that was that was so much fun i am never going to
unappreciate the level of work it takes to keep a
straight face during so many of these scenes with
blue screens you got to use your imagination
so what's always most striking to me is how
when you're doing these scenes that in the
movie they're so serious a lot of the time
and then you watch the blue person you're like oh
[ __ ] i had no idea how much fun it might have
been actually do that scene it's just like the
peter's looking at each other when andrew's doing
the breathing i think that's the shot from when
they're looking at peter where they think he's
going to kill green goblin and so that moment
right there something somewhat like the wire
effects of how complicated that must be there were
times where wired around like why are they wired
yeah and why is it so hard for him to like get
out like the apparatus that you're in must be very
restricting and must be also very heavy and yeah
it looks surprisingly awkward to be in the wire
get up when in the movie it's made to look like
everything is so fluid and smooth like that whole
thing with dr strange where he keeps slipping
on his way down and stuff like that and it's
it's fun to remember that you know in these
huge giant highly polished movies that you know
in the day-to-day there is still a lot of just
really silly little things that happen that you
got to work around that you got to problem solve
yeah to see both iterations too because you know
like the suit is iconic and to see like at which
points they're in the suits versus which points
they're in just motion capture suits to be painted
over with cgi entirely later i feel like those
things are are fun and telling because especially
like you know with tom holland's suit it seems
like naturally there would be a lot more digital
effects to go into that whereas yeah with uh toby
and andrew you know you get the classic suits
and there's something that just feels like so
much more fun and tangible and to be there on the
day like in the actual suit has to do something
wholly different to your performance or put you
in a different mindset and you know the amount of
bridging of the gap you already have to do against
these green screens and stuff like that like these
are so fun but they're also still a great kind
of glimpse into the movie magic that helps these
things to soar to the heights that they do you
know yeah and if anything what this really gave me
was i want an r-rated vulgar version of spider-man
no way home where all the scenes where they use
the f-bombs throughout or those are the takes
that i really want to see the most because it's
so unusual to see them say the f-word even though
i've seen all these actors do other things where
they are swearing or sometimes in interviews with
their swearing but when they're in costume like
i don't seem like doc ox hey father and it just
seems so strange to me so i want to see like a
lot more of that and i was also surprised by the
amount of improv it seemed like some of those
scenes that were letting them improvise like when
he is saying like there's an electric man there's
a dinosaur she was keeping a straight face for
most of it so i'm not surprised by how much improv
there is but i would like a cool breakdown from
john watson this scene was improvised more that
part was improvised more i liked like the little
nuances the little touches those are some of my
favorite things of something as simple as like
a little andrew garfield line i'm like i love
you guys of how he wanted to do that how he came
up with that line and so whatever other little
reaction responses like you know freaking harrison
ford and han solo saying i know instead of i love
you back those are like the iconic [ __ ] and
and i feel like a movie like this it's sprinkled
throughout for so much of the film and i want
to see more of that but hey man this behind the
scenes i'm really looking forward to did you guys
already make it pre-order i hope you pre-ordered
spider-man no way home anyway thank you so much
for being here this was fun appreciate you guys
sending my way and uh thank you to walking
dead no man's land for sponsoring the video
don't know why you interrupted me there
but i'll take it i'll take it i'll take it